hallo leute hier wieder einmal waren und
willkommen zu einem video in dem eine
26-jährige frau eine klopapier torte
machen möchte ich muss euch nicht über
aufklären wir leben gerade alle in
sozialer distanz zueinander was sehr
vernünftig ist denn wir wollen
verhindern dass sich das virus zu
schnell verbreitet ich hoffe natürlich
dass es euch allen gut geht und wir
kommen jetzt eigentlich auch schon dazu
warum ich eine klopapier torte machen
möchte ich bin nicht hier um
hamsterkäufe zu kritisieren das ist
nicht meine aufgabe ich habe keine
familie zu versorgen ich habe nur meinen
timo der in seinem arbeitszimmer hock
dem reicht eine pizza allerdings ist das
phänomen mit diesem klopapier ich weiß
nicht ja es ist einfach ein phänomen
klopapier was wird gehortet ich kann da
als kleinen tipp sagen es gibt länder
die wirklich ohne klopapier leben
da macht man einfach nur ein bisschen
wasser an seinen büchern und dann ist es
wieder sauber aber natürlich wir kennen
klopapier wir lieben klopapier und dann
kam ich habe lange nicht gebacken ich
habe wirklich lust mal wieder ein motiv
torte zu machen
klopapier es jetzt wirklich nicht so
anstrengend als motiv ich freue mich und
zum thema einkauf noch mal als anregung
für euch falls ihr in einem haus wohnt
mit mehreren bewohnern klippe unten ein
zettel an und bietet an einzukaufen für
ältere personen denen das ist nett wir
beginnen natürlich mit unserem
kuchenteig und die zutaten dafür sind
vier eier 200 gramm zucker ein halber
teelöffel wandel extra 200 milliliter so
200 gramm mehl ganz heiße ware
100 gramm stärke eine prise salz und
darf in unsere zutaten
zuerst müssen wir die eier uhr so sieht
ziemlich aus einfach augen zu und durch
nichts daneben gegangen
dann müsst ihr 200 gramm zucker also
schüssel machen und unser salz reihen
mrd
wo so und damit eben jetzt richtig beim
rühren zu schauen könnt bewegen würden
sitze und so jetzt wird einfach probiert
in der zeit können wir schon mal die
trockenen zutaten zusammen mischen
man sieht schon mega gut aus
backpulver vergessen in die trockenen
zutaten hinein
habt ihr schon mal darüber nachgedacht
jetzt mal ganz kurz mit ob diese soziale
distanz bedeutet ja auch das mal mit
seinem partner die ganze seiner wohnung
sein muss also die haben schon mehr
gestritten
200 milliliter slk 200 milliliter öl
jetzt müssen wir unsere mail hinein
sieben ist aber so ein schritt den mache
ich nicht gerne so sieht das alles aus
dieser tag ist richtig glücklich wenn
ihr mich schon ein bisschen schaut dann
könnt ihr direkt hier
und ja meinen backpapier so ein bisschen
schmutzig weil ich öfter benutzt also
ich benutze zwei kleine backformen weil
ich denke dass übereinander gestapelt
also mit mit creme noch dazwischen
könnte das schon die form einer klorolle
haben zum 1
zwischendurch mal irgendwie schon
trinken ja nicht getraut wir verteilen
unseren teig auf unsere formen new york
waren also ich schätze mal so 30 minuten
brauchen sie schon im auge
[Musik]
alexa stelle den timer auf 30 minuten
meine damen und herren der kuchen wurden
gebacken und kann abkühlen aber wenn sie
jetzt dachten dass wir untätig dabei
zuschauen wie abkühlt haltet ein voll
leid wir kümmern uns um die cremes und
für unsere füllung und zum bestreichen
brauchen wir sahne und schokolade
mein plan ist es eine
vollmilchschokolade füllung zu machen
und eine weiße ganache denn unser von
dong ist ja weiß und dann ist es
praktisch wenn von außen des weißes okay
wir brauchen für unsere schokoladen
füllung nehmen wir sahne und geben die
in ein und kochen wie auch in der zeit
in der unsere sahne aufkochen möchte
schneiden wir die schokolade klein
[Musik]
und jetzt so rühren umfüllen und zur
seite stellen wir sogar noch nummer zwei
und nun dass unsere weiße schokolade
dran und dann denken wir an die saale
die wir eingehen kopf machen müssen
[Musik]
wisst ihr was mir gerade sehr ironisch
ausfällt ich habe laktosefreie sahne
gekauft aber weiße vor allem schokolade
unsere sahne kocht und hier nochmal das
gleiche spiel und schnell rühren gibt es
eigentlich mal wieder eine torte und
kuchen den ich vor irgend einem youtuber
retten kann hat in letzter zeit sich
julie wieder irgendwas ran getraut was
ich retten soll
ach scheiße ich habe fehler gemacht
leute ich habe mich verlesen ich sollte
eigentlich 600 gramm ganache machen wenn
ich zum bestreichen haben will und jetzt
habe ich nur 300 gebracht
wir sollten das alles essen guck mal ob
ich noch weiße schokolade habe ich habe
eine gefunden aber dies seit einem jahr
abgelehnt da ist das denn ich mir jetzt
keinen unterschied
wisst ihr das ist die 5 minuten regeln
beziehungsweise die zwölf monate redet
sagte aber bitte timo nichts davon okay
es bleibt unter uns
nach zehn jahren haben wir dann endlich
unsere galashow
ok die müssen jetzt auch abkühlen jetzt
alles abkühlen und wir sehen uns später
wieder nach systematisch leute ta ta ta
2000 jahre später und kuchen böden sind
jetzt abgekühlt war das so saftig zu
schneiden
[Musik]
der ist das perfekt geworden okay die
creme die haben wir schöne schokoladen
garage schön braun ihr wisst was ich
damit gemeint habe
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich zu viel immer ich nehme
ein bisschen was von dieser fahnenfleck
hier drauf damit es gut festhält so
kommt jetzt der kuchen drauf nur ein
bisschen aus wie mousse au chocolat
jetzt nochmal boden alle creme die wir
noch haben und in seiner letzten wenn
das mich eine klorolle ist oder mache
ich auch nicht und da stellen wir jetzt
in den kühlschrank damit das schön so
bleibt so wie kommen sie im garten
schauen wir mal aber aus unserer wenn ja
wie ghana und das findet auch in die
mitte schäuble sieht gut aus
mein freund meines wir beachten dass
hier
und das hier ok retorte
[Musik]
mir fällt gerade ein wir müssen ja noch
so ein löchlein da oben machen ich
stecke jetzt einfach mal mit einem glas
wein sondern dass muss jetzt aber auch
aus sollen jetzt im kühlschrank mein
pony ist heute ein bisschen crazy toro
kommen wir zum grand finale und zwar
brauchen wir dafür form doch ich glaube
wir können die einfach so drauf legen
oder es muss ein bisschen größer werden
es muss ein perfekt mit ich sein
dann hab ich einfach so bleiben sie
daraus süß aus somit mal irgendwo
anfangen das sind so runter drücken wo
mein gott es ist anstrengend also hier
haben wir schon ein kleines loch zu
vermerken das ist aber nicht so schlimm
weil wir müssen noch eine rolle drüber
machen klopapier was schon viel
mitgemacht hat als nächstes möchte ich
so ein blatt machen was so gerade von
der klorolle so abfällt hast du nicht
genug
[Musik]
ja das ist perfekt bis die sache sieht
aus wie so eine klorolle die mal aus
gewickelt waren und wieder eingewickelt
wurde in die verschieden ist meine es
könnte schlimmer aussehen sie dir da wo
die klorolle anfängt so das kommt den
kühlschrank letzter schritt ich bin so
glücklich sprits glasur und die kann man
natürlich mit eiweiß selber machen oder
man hat hier praktische fertigmischungen
250 gramm pulver mit 30 milliliter
verarbeiten
[Musik]
die jetzt denke ich dass wir irgendwie
der ahnung von dem was ich jetzt tun
doch jedes unser klopapier dort wo ja
das forderungs haut geworden
ich habe noch was vergessen schwarzes
polo für die mittel so ist brauchen wir
eine gute größe wenn wir unser tranken
tower schott glas duo günther und haben
schwarzen kreis und der kommt jetzt mein
gott aber geht das macht ganz schön was
ausländern schwarzer kreis drin ist so
jetzt kommt spritzbeutel jetzt mit ganz
kleine spitze abschneiden schon einmal
mehr an
[Musik]
oh mein gott ich bin so angespannt grad
ich liebe sie sie sieht so gut aus
[Musik]
irgendwann später aber klappe einmal
klatschen bitte jawoll perfekt
action-kino hat die torte noch nicht
gesehen
bist du gespannt ich bin halt auf jeden
fall der mann ohne ohne durch die kamera
zu schauen sie anschaut war geil was uns
noch wiking mäßiger gemacht hätte
dadurch jetzt die kritik anbringt ja
wäre wenn du mit zuckerguss ja quasi
haben wir mal so logos drauf wenn das
ein schriftzug gemacht hätte so könnt
ihr nicht dass verschiedene es gibt von
befriedigend ein bisschen im print
kritiker kommen wie sie voll gut aus ist
einmal nicht so hart zu mir meine
anmerkungen papier
rolle klopapier timo ich gehe mal ganz
kurz auf klo falsch ja also von von
einer bewertung ich würde mir eine acht
geben was willst du mir geben ich würde
gerne 8,1 geben sie anschneiden
ich habe vor das schlimmste die dann
angst und schnelligkeit von hinten und
nun stellen wir uns wieder der
wichtigsten frage wie sieht die torte
von innen aus er ist okay sie dringt aus
wie so eine falsche tor
also ich habe heute wieder einfach
gemeinschaft sie da drauf aber ich habe
es so aus versehen drauf ich habe es
immer so obst es ist doch cool geworden
bei während ich das immer mache sterbe
ich eigentlich vor panik das innere eine
klorolle ja und das gefällt mir schon
mal nett da sie nicht der wichtigsten
freundlich und der frage wenn ich die
größe von wolf fan
tipp macht den boden einen tag vorher
ganze feld nicht weil dann hat er zeit
so griff zu sammeln eine einheit bilden
also widerstand zu leisten
oh gott oder so ist jetzt nicht so dass
eine so überwältigende geschmäcker
überraschend abermals ist stabil
doch mit der schule dringend mehr geld
ich frisch und lecker und töten
ich bin immer bei von unnötig das ist
doch genauso wie mit kluger ps voll
unbedingt dass man so viel davon hat bei
der post ab waren hamster einkäufen dass
ihr anderen leuten nichts wegnehmen
deckt euch gut 1 aber übertreibt es auf
mich weil zum beispiel andere leute
warum auch körper 4
das ist die moral von diesem video und
ansonsten wünsche ich euch eine
angenehme quarantänezeit und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten video wiederkauf euro
[Musik]